[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings we have
more of our exclusive interview with r
kelly survivor asriel clary a jury
convicted kelly this week of nine
charges now five of those related crimes
committed against her including
transporting a minor across state lines
to engage in sexual activity clary who
is now 23 years old says kelly abused
her verbally and physically for years
the first time we met her she was 21
years old and she was still living with
r kelly we spoke with her again
yesterday it's her first interview since
the trial
come on in ezreal
well you look good thank you so do you
have a seat
i'll just start with this
i'm really glad to see you again
because i wasn't sure i'd ever get to
talk to you again
i'm very happy to be here and and see
you again as well it feels like a full
circle moment to me when we first met
asrielle clary in march of 2019 she had
been living with r kelly for almost five
years and was one of his fiercest
supporters because you guys don't know
the truth you guys
i'm believing some
facade that our parents are staying this
is all lives for money clary and another
woman joycelyn savage told us then that
they were in a relationship with the
embattled r b singer but clary left the
apartment she shared with kelly in
chicago seven months after our interview
i was lost and
i would i felt invisible and
you know i gave someone that control
over me to basically make me do whatever
it was that they wanted me to do and act
however they wanted me to act during r
kelly's trial she testified that he
began sexually abusing her when she was
just 17 years old at the time of the
interview with us were you afraid when
you were sitting there talking to us
i was he did his interview first i
didn't do this stuff this is not me i'm
fighting for my life
y'all killing me with this
he came in
and he told us to be angry and be upset
and she's gonna try to do this and you
get it we told you that yes and and so
we were we came in angry so he told you
be angry yes and um
i was scared because i was like
i don't want the world to see me this
way
you know
i don't
i'm loving i'm caring i'm compassionate
and um
no one got to see that side of me yeah
you know it's interesting because your
dad called me after and said that is not
my daughter
that is not who she is that is not how
she speaks that is not what she believes
during the trial you testified that
you said i was not honest in the
interview that you did with us
were you not honest about
everything
everything everything yes
you you know
before that interview um you know he had
us practicing
every single day
practicing what
answering questions and if he didn't
like our answer he would tell us exactly
what to say and how to say it so anytime
you mention anything
yeah i'm just i'm stunned by this yeah
so anytime you mention
anytime you mention anything about
sexual preference we already know to say
i'm not here to talk about that
because that's what he told us to say
every single day that's exactly what you
said first of all i'm not here to talk
about my personal life and i would never
share with no one what i do in or
outside of the bedroom so when the
interview was over and you all go back
to his apartment the three of you what
is the conversation
he was so happy he was happy he was so
happy he was like you guys did amazing
you know you did so well you carried
yourself so well i believe he even like
got food and wanted to celebrate that's
how happy he was
with that interview and i was just there
like
wow
what did he think about how he came
across in the interview
truthfully
he think i think he he believed that he
had he done he had done well
he he felt like he had really uh did a
made a great reflection of himself and
where he was in life and how all these
women were lying on him and how all
these people were just you know out to
get him and you know that sympathy card
that he just loved so much did you ever
have conversations when he wasn't around
to say this is not good this is not
healthy we got to get the hell out of
here did you ever have any conversations
i feel like a lot of people tried but
everyone always got beat over it because
he was very good at manipulating the
situation so
even if
he knew or not he would basically say he
could come in his room right now and he
would say you know i've already spoken
to joy she already told me exactly what
you guys have been talking about you
have five minutes to be honest or you're
going to be thrown around this entire
room
everything that we
were living in had become very normal
and
i had to break out of that i had to
realize that this is actually abnormal
yeah the dysfunction was so prevalent
that after a while it did feel normal to
you it did because it was not only me it
was other women other women who were
older than me you know when i met him at
17 he had four other women and so these
women are all normalizing his actions
and then you have assistance normalizing
his actions and you have workers and
security and everyone else that
normalizes it so
you me being very young at that time i
just learned to normalize it what do you
think anybody could have said or done
to help you leave the situation sooner
nothing nothing nothing
i feel like that is something that i
would have had to have woken up from
myself something that i would have had
to realize on myself
and you know a lot of people don't
realize with victims the more you try to
help them the more it upsets them
sometimes you know your interview stands
out because you are one of the few who
we've heard
who defended him so vocally and so
adamantly and now ends up testifying
against him well your testimony was very
key
as real it was very key it was very
graphic it was very painful some of it
was so graphic the judge wouldn't even
allow it to be be released
um to the public
and i'm wondering what it was like for
you sitting there
looking at him while you're testifying
about what your life had been like with
him
i feel like
it was
it was very disturbing
to have to relive those moments and um
i don't know a piece of me was happy
because i felt like happy
yeah
because i felt like this person no
longer has control over me you know you
you you don't tell me what to do and
what to wear and where to go and how
long to be in a room anymore so
i think the fact that you're sitting
here today
is very brave and very courageous that
you would come back and sit down and
want people to see yeah who you really
are
i think it's very important
you know even i have to take
accountability for my actions
it's okay to reevaluate your life
it is okay to change your mind you know
you are never too old to wake up and say
hey i thought this was good for me but
it's actually not yeah and so i feel
like that's why it was important for me
to come back here and uh see you again
because
it is okay to change your mind it is
okay to apologize and forgive yourself
more importantly and now that's really
what i had to do
r kelly as you know has long denied
allegations of sexual misconduct with
the underage girls where i'm happy to
say that uh asriel is in therapy
you know she came to the interview alone
which surprised me i thought somebody
would be with her she came by herself
when she testified her therapist was
with her in another room and she knows
that she still has a lot of work to do
but what happened to her i was really
glad to see her in such a different
space because what she's been through
when i say unspeakable things i won't i
won't go there only just say at one
point feces are involved take your mind
wherever you want to go it's that
graphic
the humiliation the degradation that
happened to this young woman and the
fact that she's still afraid because
she's worried she still gets death
threats from our kelly's supporters she
lives in fear
and you know at the time you know she
said very disparaging things against her
family she said imagine i hadn't seen
anybody for five years i'd never seen
any other woman other than yourself who
wasn't in an abusive relationship that's
why that made such a mark on her
she she said she gave him control yes
which almost places the blame on herself
herself right do you realize that she
realized at this age that he was
manipulating her and that he actually
took control yeah she realized it
realizes that now though nate but at the
time you know he was very good in terms
of grooming them for sure you know and
and
you would think that everything was fine
when we came to do that interview he
would say oh they're out shopping which
is what he would do he would send them
shopping so they came back with all
these shopping bags to show these people
aren't being held against their will
they're happy they're out shopping
yes yes it's all very very very
manipulative amazing